المشاهدين الكرام كما ذكر جمال العاصمه
الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث ترتبط بجسور مهمه
ونقاط حيويه كما نعلم اذا ما اقتربنا اكثر
الى العاصمه الخرطوم فهذه الخرطوم الكبرى
كما نشاهد على الشاشه والتي تنقسم الى
ثلاثه اقسام الخرطوم بحري التي تاتي بهذا
الشكل الشرق الشق الشرقي الشمالي الشرقي
من العاصمه وام درمان التي تشكل الجهه
الغربيه والشماليه الغربيه من العاصمه
وبقيت المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي مدينه الخرطوم
وطبعا كما تشاهدون على الشاشه هي اصغر
مساحات ما تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى هذه هي
المناطق الثلاث تقسمها الانهار كما نشاهد
على الشاشه تقسم بين الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري نهر النيل الازرق القادم من جهه
اثيوبيا
ويقسم ايضا من الجهه الغربيه نهر النيل
الا اللذان يشكلان مع بعضهما نهر النيل
الذي يصعد الى مصر على هذه الجسور هناك
على هذه الانهار هناك جسور الجسور بدرجه
اساسيه من المنطقه الشرقيه جسر سوبا
المنشيه بين الخرطوم والخرطوم البحري
وايضا كوبر والنيل الازرق والمك نمر على
الخرطوم وام درمان هناك جسر الافتيحاب على
الجهه الغربيه والجهه الشماليه بين
الخرطوم بحري واندرمان كما نشاهد حلفايه
وشنبات الصراع الان بين الطرفين على من
يسيطر على هذه الجسور وتحديدا الجسور
الجسور المنطقه الغربيه لان قوات الدعم
السريع تحاول الدفع بامداداتها من المناطق
الغربيه للبلاد وتحديدا دارفور وبالتالي
السيطره على الجسور يعني بان هذه القوات
ستكون قادره على الانتقال بسلاسه من
المناطق الغربيه الى المناطق الشرقيه في
العاصمه وتحدي من ام درمان ومناطق ما وراء
ام درمان دارفور وتلك المناطق الى الخرطوم
وتحديدا الخرطوم بحري ومدينه الخرطوم هذا
لا يعني بطبيعه الحال ان القوات الدعم
السريع تسيطر على المناطق الغربيه من
البلاد وانها تريد التقدم نحو المناطق
الشرقيه او العكس بان الجيش يسيطر على
مناطق الشرقيه ويريد التقدم المناطق
الغربيه وانما القتال اصبح منذ الساعات
الاولى او منذ الايام الاولى للقتال في
هذه المعارك تحول الى حرب شوارع لان قوات
الدعم السريع ترتكز في اكثر من مكان في
العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا بطبيعه الحال قوات
الجيش ترتكز في اكثر من مكان ما يعطي اليد
العليا للجيش على قوات الدعم السريع هو
سلاح الطيران التابع للجيش السوداني الذي
يضرب بعنف مواقع ارتكاز الدعم السريع الذي
ياخذ من الاحياء مراكز له ومن بعض الاحياء
المهمه مثل منطقه الشماليه الشرقيه لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما انتقلنا اكثر الى
صوره اقرب طبعا هذه الجسور تتوزع السيطره
فيها بين قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
السوداني الاهم من هذه الجسور باعتقاد
المحللين العسكريين
على المنطقه الشماليه من الخرطوم الذي
يقسم بين ام درمان وخرطوم بحري جسر شنبات
تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم السريع وجسر
الحلفاء حلفايه تسيطر عليه قوات الجيش
لانه قوات الدعم السريع تتخذ من هذه لها
مراكز اساسيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
من الخرطوم بحري بجوار جسم شمبات وبالتالي
السيطره على شنبات بالنسبه لها نقطه
ارتكاز ضروريه جدا لقوات الدعم السريع اذا
ما دخلنا اكثر الى هذه المنطقه فنحن نتحدث
عن المناطق الشماليه من مدينه الخرطوم هذه
مدينه الخرطوم كما ذكرنا المدينه التي
نتحدث عنها التي تقع بين النيلين طبعا
بطبيعه الحال قبل قليل شاهدنا الانفجارات
الدخان من هذه المنطقه مقرن النيلين مكان
اجتماع النيل الازرق منين الابيض في هذه
المنطقه هذه المنطقه الاكثر حساسيه في
المعارك التي تدور الان لاننا نتحدث عن
محيط القصر الرئاسي والمقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذه
المنطقه ككل تقريبا هي مسرح العمليات
بدرجه اساسيه بصوره اقرب الى هذه المنطقه
الشماليه مدينه الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم
العاصمه فنحن نتحدث عن مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه كما نشاهد على الشاشه في
هذه النقطه الغايه في الاهميه حيث تتمركز
قوات الجيش وتتهم قوات الدعم السريع بانها
تشن هجمات على هذه المنطقه وتحاول فصل
سيطرتها على القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه سواء قادمه من الجهه الشرقيه او
من الجهه الشماليه وهنا تاتي اهميه الجسور
في الربط بين مناطق قوات خرطوم بحري في
الشمال ومدينه الخرطوم في الجنوب وبالتالي
السيطره على هذه الجسور يعني سهوله التقدم
بشكل سريع على هذه المنطقه الغايه في
الاهميه وتحديدا القصر الجمهوري الذي
شاهدنا في محيطه الانفجارات لتكون معركه
الجسور معركه غايه في الاهميه السيطره على
جسور المدينه العاصمه ستؤدي بطبيعه الحال
الى تغيير هذه القواعد في الاش